Salut à tous c'est les pêcheurs de trésor, aujourd'hui nous sommes à Avignon
On vous aurez bien fait un tour des citadelles
mais nous ce qu'on cherche c'est les endroits où on est susceptibles
de trouver des belles choses dans l'eau
là on est au bord d'un lac et j'ai repéré quelque chose,
il y a une forme assez particulière en face,
Sans tomber
Rasta, vient là
Rasta c'est fait des amis pêcheurs qui mangent quelque chose
Oh les capsules et les clous
C'est horrible, c'est un carnage
Bon ici, je pense que ça n'a jamais été pêché à l'aimant,
Je te laisse le temps de réussir à sortir tout ça de l'aimant et après on recommence sur l'objet spécial là bas
Ca se soulève, c'est un écran ou une télé ?
La quantité de capsules que tu as encore ...
Ici ça doit être terrible
Le trophée, nickel
Elle est un peu abîmée, elle est cassée,
Ca va être infernal les capsules j'ai l'impression
Alors qu'est ce que tu as de beau ?
Regarde ça encore, terrible, la quantité
Regardez, j'ai fait une sorte de boîtier électronique bizarre avec du caoutchouc
je sais pas trop ce que c'est, si vous savez un commentaire
En même temps, une douille
Qui a été percutée donc c'est du 17.57, ça fait penser à du kalashnikov,
Ouais AK je pense ouais
Intéressant, surtout tiré c'est pas mal,
quelqu'un est venu jeter ses douilles donc il voulait pas laisser de preuves,
attention comme dirait Bondi Treasure Hunter
tu m'as mouillé avec cette eau dégueulasse
je m'en excuse
Ce que j'aimerais sortir aujourd'hui justement c'est un AK47
parce que c'est vrai que les armes automatiques c'est pas notre truc, on fait des pistolets,
on fait des revolvers, des fusils, de chasse, mais on aimerait bien trouver un petit AK47,
ça nous ferait plaisir, on ne le garderait pas, il paraît que ça chauffe pas mal à Avignon
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est ici aussi, ouais c'est parce qu'il y a beaucoup de spots aussi,
donc on va voir, pour l'instant beaucoup de canettes, tu sais qu'il y a tellement de canettes
que tu le sens, je sens l'aimant qui frotte sur les capsules, clac clac clac clac clac clac clac,
oh t'as quelque chose, un alternateur, ouais c'est un alternateur avec du cuivre dedans,
Pas mal, sympa
Ca c'est un morceau de mouliné,
Je reconnais
Si on fait un aimant sans capsules, on change de spot
Impossible
Ca va que l'eau n'est pas encore très chaude
Il y a comme des égouts qui se déversent là bas
J'ai jeté mon aimant bien contre la rive
J'ai quelque chose d'assez gros, ça a fait un petit CLOCK , donc j'espère que je vais réussir à le garder tout le long
Quand vous sentez la corde qui frotte, vous avez une petite notion du poids quand même
Je dirais 2-3 kilos, intéressant, en sachant que maintenant il se charge de capsules de bières
On va regarder ensemble ce qu'on a
C'est une caisse !
Ah ! C'était sûr ici
Malheureusement elle est ouvert
mais ça fait plaisir, c'est bon signe
Intéressant
On va regarder sur l'aimant si il n'y a pas quelque pièces, ca pourrait nous donner une indication
Il y a un dépôt sauvage de clous ici
Ca va être compliqué de nettoyer ça
C'est rempli d'objets je pense, c'est un bon spot
Ouais c'était sûr que c'était un bon spot
On testera là bas où il y a le pêcheur, ça a l'air sympa
Il y a une rampe pour envoyer un scooter directement
Il y a une petite pêcheuse aussi non ? - Ouais ouais, mais bon elle est accompagnée
T'es prêt ?
Ca doit venir d'une voiture ça
Ouais je pense
Il est fossilisé
C'est bon signe, il y a des vieilles choses
Je pensais que ça puerai plus que ça vu l'endroit
Ca reste raisonnable
Si vous savez ce que c'est, dites le nous en commentaire
Ah oui la bouteille de protoxyde d'azote
Un classique malheureusement le protoxyde d'azote
Ouais on risque d'en faire pas mal aujourd'hui, ça ne m'étonne pas
CREAMDELUX, la fameuse marque dont on avait parlé dans un  épisode à propos de cette drogue
Qui n'est pas encore considérée comme une drogue en France mais il commence à l'être dans pas mal de pays
On va faire un petit lancer de la main droite, attention
Regarde, je fais une montre aussi
Ah oui quand même. - Elle est bizarre, une mini montre, tu sais que ça peut être des montres qui coutent chers
quand c'est petit comme ça ouais, c'est miniaturisé dans des bracelets
Oh le bordel
Pour te faciliter le truc il y a des clous avec
Quel enfer
Une carette de Pepsi collector
C'est horrible
Si je ne finis pas avec un clou planté dans la main avant la fin de la journée ce sera un miracle
Je vais attraper le tétanos là, c'est pas possible
Capsules
Oh il y a quelque chose au milieu
Une montre à gousset
Miniature
Elle est jolie, elle brille bien, elle est cuivrée,
Cuivrée mais il y a du métal au milieu,
Elle ressort plutôt bien
Deuxième montre que je trouve ici, donc je vais continuer
On cuit et on ne peut pas se baigner, l'eau est trop sale
Tu attrapes des trucs bizarres
2 heures de route avant de prendre la douche, on va éviter
Je n'ai pas envie de rester deux heures dans mon jus comme ça
Qu'est ce que tu as de beau ?
bah écoute des capsules
La quantité est totalement incroyable, j'ai jamais vu ça, mais il y a des
Il y a des coins en France comme à  Paris où c'est terrible
Il va falloir aller chercher un autre seau
J'ai plus envie ...
C'est un enfer
Si jamais vous devez vous débarrasser d'un objet compromettant, vous le jetez à l'eau et vous videz des brouettes de clous par dessus
Je pense que n'importe quel pêcheur à l'aimant va remonter deux ou trois fois l'aimant comme ça et va abandonner
Votre objet sera en sécurité au fond de l'eau
Pensez juste à revenir de temps en temps pour rajouter des clous
On a repéré un petit lac qui a l'air bien sympa et on arrive à peine sur place
et on trouve cet indice.
C'est plutôt bizarre, d'après sa rouille je ne pense pas qu'il ait séjourné dans l'eau
Il est plus rouillé ici.
En tout cas,  c'est un cadre de gros scooter Peugeot
Il pèse une trentaine de kilos déjà
C'est un spot prometteur pour ce qu'il va y avoir dans l'eau,
donc nous ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va sortir nos aimants et on va tout de suite attaquer la pêche à l'aimant
et bien sûr on est en compagnie de Rasta, mais qu'est ce qu'il fait il va à l'autre côté, qui s'en va,
Voilà le spot
Alors, je crois que je n'ai pas de ferrailles mais j'ai encore plein d'algues avec des écrevisses
Elles sont plutôt grosses par rapport à leur taille habituelle dans le coin
On va les récolter et on va les manger. De toute façon c'est des écrevisses de Louisiane
C'est interdit de les relâcher
Regardez, elles sont belles
En même temps on va quand même regarder l'aimant si on n'a pas de ferraille
Seulement quelques bouts
C'est très ancien
Il y en a une grosse là
Une de plus
Ce n'est plus de la pêche à l'aimant, c'est de la pêche aux ecrevisses
Je ne sais pas si vous connaissez la chaine de Marius qui fait de la chasse et de la pêche
On n'est pas trop chasse mais vu que c'est interdit de les relâcher,  je pense qu'aujourd'hui on va vraiment chasser les écrevisses.
Pêchons des écrevisses !
Si il y a de la ferraille en plus, tant mieux
Vidéo peut-être un peu particulière, il n'y a pas trop de ferrailles,
On va vous faire une pêche à l'écrevisse avec des aimants
Là ! Une écrevisse
Belle bête encore, ma première
Il y en a une là, je t'ai eu ma petite
Mince, elle s'en va
Je vais regarder si il n'y en a pas d'autre là
Toi, je t'ai vue
Il y en avait une autre par là qui se cache
Une de plus
On va bien manger. - On les feras au barbecue
Pour l'instant tu en as attrapée une, tu en mangeras une
Moi  j'en ai 15
J'en vois déjà une
Pas mal, un beau spécimen encore une fois,
Tu as eu ta deuxième ?
Deux d'un coup !
Bien joué,  tu auras le droit d'en manger trois
Elles sont très belles celles là
Marius chasse et pêche n'a qu'à bien se tenir
Avec des aimants la chasse est mieux
C'est plus artisanal, on espère quand même trouver un bout de ferraille mais j'y crois de moins en moins
Il y en a une là !
Yes ! En vrai ça marche trop bien
Oui c'est efficace
Il ne faut pas hésiter à fouiller
Comme quoi, la pêche à l'aimant peut aussi nous nourrir
Ouais, de base je ne suis pas trop chasse et pêche, mais là vu que se sont des espèces invasives ça me rassure
C'est plus sympa que d'acheter des gambas d'élevage en commerce
On va attraper tout ça
Il y en a une là ouais c'est bien ce que je me disais,
Elle est blanche ce n'est pas une de Louisiane je pense
On va la manger quand même
Il y en a une là
bonjour
Elle m'a pincée elle m'a eu
Là elle se tire ! Je l'ai eu !
Je crois que j'ai enfin quelque chose
Oh oui, Baptiste, j'ai une trouvaille !
Une casserole
C'est parfait ça pour faire cuire nos écrevisses
Regardez on a tout ce qu'il faut maintenant, plus qu'à faire un petit feu et on est bon
On sort les algues et il faut regarder aux endroits ça frétille.
Op ! J'en ai une
Voilà !
Là il y en a une autre
Voilà le résultat de la pêche à l'aimant du jour
On va se faire ça au barbecue ça va être très bon
Dites nous si vous avez déjà goûté des écrevisses de rivière. Ca m'étonnerait
parce que très peu de personnes les ramassent.
On a de la ferraille en même temps pour le ferrailleur
C'est cool
Allé Rasta, en selle